so gentlemen what would you tell fellow
actors about getting the business side
of their careers ready
not just the artistic side so many
artistic people say you know what I
don't want to deal with the money side I
don't want to deal with the the
logistics of my career I just want to
work on the craft is that true can you
just leave that to someone else even in
the beginning oh really I mean I would
say invest a little bit of your money
and a good accountant or a good business
manager because they're dealing with
your money so you want someone that's
reputable that deals with good people
and knows what they're doing with your
money and then you know social media is
kind of important nowadays so some sort
of online presence whether that's your
website or Facebook fan page or Twitter
and then having a good agent because
they'll obviously filter a lot of the
rubbish out and only give me the stuff
that you really need to be yeah under
businessman and asked us could you deal
with them what your business yeah you'd
be good at ten percent twenty fine see
yeah the worst business well speaking of
Twitter with with great power comes
great responsibility so do you feel any
type of sort of weight on your back to
have responsible tweets are you
conscious of what you put out there so
that if your fans see it it's it's
acceptable it's it's well I mean my
Twitter page is a reflection of me and I
I'm not racist or sexist or homophobic
I'm not fascist or you know I don't have
with elements of my personality so I
might be a little
aggressive to someone who's the nasty
towards me but I'll never throw the
first stone you know and I'll usually
just show that people are being
inappropriate and leave it that you know
but if someone gets nasty then and I
feel like it I might point out that
they're dating badly but I don't I don't
tend to swear on Twitter I don't tend to
say anything this inflammatory for no
good reason so if someone prompts you
it's on Facebook yeah and I'll call out
people that I think are behaving badly
like I've called out Bill O'Reilly a few
times and Piers Morgan a few times but
for the most by family applause I'm kind
of new to the whole tweet thing as I say
I do it through other my band so it's
not totally personal like all the guys
in the band tweet stuff and I kind of
keep it as quite a funny thing and
something to put some faultless and I
don't really use it you know if you
could of course any sort of personal
beliefs or anything really you know I
keep it away you know it's about the
band really and lastly what do you do to
recharge
I know LA gets a little bit hectic
sometimes sometimes projection sets in
or people become a little bit jaded with
the business what do you do to recharge
so you feel better
I travel quite a bit you know I mean if
I'm in LA and I don't have time to go
somewhere on a plane then I'll drive to
Joshua Tree or Palm Springs or Santa
Barbara just try and get away for the
weekend you know hang around with people
that aren't actors apart from Billy who
is an actor you know I'll hang around
with people in the music business so all
people in different walks of life and
then Billy and I both enjoy surfing here
and there yogurt
fantastic yeah having trouble is a great
one and yogurt is probably the biggest
thing to gain of destress good
perspective on things
all right thank you guys thank you